I don't we didn't get off to the
greatest start but I want to fix all
that won't keep you safe and fed give
you all the things a kid should have
[Music]
Orlan
Orlin
[Music]
after I fix up your side I'm gonna patch
a progestin No
[Music]
it's making me stronger
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new flash footage to break down
this is for the Thanksgiving episode
next week but we also have the full
official synopsis for the 100th episode
so I'll explain that too I'll start with
this footage then I'll talk about the
hundredth episode there's a new round of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a flash related comment on the video so
first things first if you remember that
weather wizard post-credit scene from a
couple episodes ago i'll play it in a
second where the wizard showed up in
iron Heights he's been there for a while
he was trying to get rag doll to join
his new team of rogues so just set up
for a weather wizard episode we didn't
know exactly what it was gonna happen
but now it's confirmed that it's going
to be next week's episode
get in there freak along
province
[Music]
we all are a near brother you see Ron
you're not alone welcome to Metta max
and who are you my name's Martin there's
lightning coming and when it gets here I
promise it will best place to be is in
the iron stored with me storms come into
town the storm this coming though is his
daughter who's trying to kill him per
the synopsis so her name's gonna be
weather which in they're doing a version
of weather Wizards son from the comics
so if you're not a big comic book reader
weather wizard in the comics had a
one-night stand with a police officer in
Keystone City then later learns that she
had a child in the baby the son has the
ability to control the elements without
the need of a control rod like the comic
book weather wizard does so they've
already done a couple different things
with the TV show version of the
character like this version of weather
wizard is a natural metahuman he can
control weather without needing any
special tech but they did develop the
lightsaber looking weather control rod
that's meant to suppress his powers but
he took that back from them but he
doesn't need that in order to create
tidal waves like we were just talking
about the tidal wave episode because of
what they did with Nora's character in
last week's episode they referenced them
running on water but it sounds like
weather which his daughter that he never
maybe knew about shows up and is trying
to kill him
it's not really clear whether or not she
is gonna be an evil metahuman in the
future or if she's gonna be a killer
frost type villain where she sort of
flip-flops back and forth a little more
ambiguous but knowing that she's gonna
be in the episode clarifies kind of
what's going on with a lightning strike
that you see get buried when Nora's
trying to save him in this footage you
probably picked up on the heavy
overtones of fathers daughters families
during the trailer so you have Barry
Endora
but it's the cicada voiceover I know we
didn't get off on the right foot he
talks about wanting to give his daughter
a normal life you saw their picture at
the end of last week's episode this is
why I put the clip at the beginning of
this video you see him constructing his
daughter's dollhouse then you see the
accident with the Dark Matter satellite
that injured her and gave him his powers
like you actually see them pull the
dagger out of him in the hospital
they're just trying to highlight the
fact why he's trying to do all this like
they want to remind you that there is a
reason why he's being so psychopathic
even though he comes off really heavy in
a lot
the scenes that he's had so far it's
making me stronger so I really hope they
stick the landing with this but I think
everybody picks up on the themes that
they're trying to play into here the
whole idea with noir here like the
reason why it seems like there's drama
going on is because she's still upset
about Barry dying in crisis on Infinite
Earths in the future in not being able
to save him so this was going on in this
moment here like she's still trying to
think of a way to save him and they
still have not explained her future
diary with all the speedforce symbols in
it yet so I'm expecting that to come
back around relatively soon but if it
wasn't clear this is not cicada when it
looks like it jumps from Barry almost
being struck with this giant lightning
bolt that looks white that's not
speedforce lightning that's just regular
lightning probably from the weather
which character who team flash is trying
to stop from killing weather wizard so
it's a bit of a funny twist on the
weather wizard flash relationship like
usually it's weather wizard going after
the flash but now the flash has to
protect him from his daughter who seems
crazy powerful I'm really hoping that
somebody makes the weather [ __ ] joke is
really obvious but like if you call
someone weather witch she's really mean
she's a villain you call them a [ __ ] so
she's weather [ __ ]
so we'll see what she feels like
hopefully she'll be a cool new villain
they can use in the future they did say
that they were introducing new younger
rogues characters so she just seems like
one of those new ones the title of the
Thanksgiving episode next week is just
oh come all ye faithful even though that
sounds like more of a Christmas title
but moving into the hundredth episode
the official title is what's past is
prologue that's a reference to the plot
of the episode but it's also reference
to all of Barry's past battles being a
prologue to the battle that he's going
to be having with cicada in the future
so the official synopsis just reads
Barry and team flash come up with a plan
to stop cicada however the plan calls
for Barry and Nora to travel back in
time to gather some key necessities
however Barry hesitates concerned about
his daughter seeing certain parts of his
life meanwhile Sherlock takes his
concerns about Nora to iris and Caitlin
turns up a key asset in the fight
against cicada so there's like a couple
really big ideas that they put forth
here Barry Nora going back in time to
find key things that will help them
fight cicada that could be knowledge
those could be objects
has done that before during season two
Barry had to go back in time to get help
from the reverse-flash in constructing a
new tachyon device that would help him
fight zoom but when it says the Barry
hesitates about showing Nora certain
parts of his life she's probably just
talking about all the worst moments that
he had with the villains so that could
include savat are during season 3 we
know that includes zoom because Tony
Todd the voice of zoom said that he was
gonna appear during the episode it could
also involve flashpoint or the
reverse-flash killing his mother like
all the biggest WTF moments in the
history of the flash we don't know
exactly what those scenes are gonna be
like but you can imagine based on the
premise just going back to all the
biggest moments but here's the thing it
also says that Sherlock follows up on
that scene that he had with Nora where
he's like who gave you the idea to come
back and change the past surely you
didn't come up with this idea by
yourself implying that Nora was working
with someone in the future that we don't
know about yet right now my early theory
is is that that was a version of eobard
thawne that was just trying to trick
Nora to precipitate circumstances that
would allow him to return like his
timeline is also probably messed up in
the future because the cicada so what
better way to fix it than trying to send
the Flash's daughter to do things rather
than go himself because the minute the
reverse-flash showed up Barry would try
to stop him but maybe it's a situation
where he's trying to use Nora like a
Trojan horse to change the timeline so
that it benefits him in the future just
a lot of early speculation because it's
the 100th episode I do expect that we'll
see some form of reverse flash either in
a previous scene that they just cut into
the episode or the legit new version of
the reverse flash the only other thing
they talk about in the episode is
Caitlin turning up a key asset in the
fight against Takeda
I assume that's a reference to killer
frost if it's not something else that
she finds because that whole final scene
during last week's episode was her
gaining access to killer frost like oh
hey we got a lot to talk about
let me know in the comments though what
do you guys most excited about for the
Thanksgiving episode in the 100
so there'll be a whole bunch more
footage dropping in the next week so
leave all your requests in the comments
below click here for my flash
Icicle episode video and click here to
learn about what's going on with the
Avengers 4 trailer and the new official
Marvel timeline thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you